Okay, so before we get into the engine, I want to go over some basic terminologies and
concepts that you'll be hearing me use throughout the duration of the course.
And I just want to make sure that we have a common language and ground when I talk about
these things.
So we'll be taking a look at what direct lighting versus indirect lighting and shadows are.
So in this case, direct lighting is the light that goes directly from the light source onto
the surface without any interference, which means that it receives the full spectrum of
the light in terms of color.
Now indirect lighting is slightly different to that.
It's when lighting's been bounced off a surface and lights another object.
Now when lighting hits that surface, that surface absorbs some of the light and the
light that gets bounced out is actually tinted.
So indirect lighting contributes to the overall mood and light intensity of the scene and
color as well.
And then the shadows are important to understand that it's essentially a real engine takes
a snapshot of a mesh from the light's point of view and projects the shadow information
onto another surface from that point of view.
So as long as we're all agreed on this, I think as I start talking about these concepts
when we talk about lighting later down the line, I think we'll all understand what it
is I'm referring to.
And I also want to take a look at the types of lighting systems that exist in the engine.
For this course, we're going to be using real time dynamic global illumination since Unreal
Engine 5 comes with Lumen, which is an incredibly powerful and strong real time global illumination
system.
But I just wanted to go over the other options that you have as well to make sure that you
understand everything that's available.
So Unreal Engine has a baked or static lighting system, which is pre-computed.
This is created using Unreal Engine's Lightmass system.
And it's similar to rendering with lighting setups like V-Ray, Corona, et cetera.
And it's really high quality, but it's baked.
So it cannot be altered at runtime.
So once you bake it, it takes quite a long time to bake if you're using the CPU.
And then once that's done, you cannot edit it at runtime, which means you can't have
a light swing, for example, and update lighting in real time if you were using a purely static
system.
There's other systems like real time dynamic lighting, which is what we're going to be
using.
Now, historically, this had no global illumination system.
So you only had direct light.
So there was no bounce light effect in the scene or anything like that for this type
of lighting.
But nowadays with Lumen and Unreal Engine 5, we do have that.
So we're going to be sticking to this sort of method, which means no baking times, nothing
to wait for, everything you see is happening in real time, and it's final straight away.
Now, as I say, Unreal Engine can use both static and dynamic lighting.
Traditionally, for architectural visualization and AEC industries in general, these projects
were typically stationary and baked.
But again, nowadays with Unreal Engine 5, we're going to be using Lumen, so we don't have
to worry so much about that.
The last type of system is hardware ray tracing.
So it's a lighting type that it's real time, just like the dynamic stuff.
However, it uses hardware ray tracing to calculate global illumination.
So all that bounce light and indirect lighting can also be calculated at runtime.
It requires very strong GPUs.
So you might have heard the Nvidia RTX card.
So that's something you're going to require if you're going to be using straight up ray
tracing.
Lumen uses software ray tracing, which means you don't need such a high end GPU.
So that's what we're going to stick to.
So those are the concepts that we need to go over.
In terms of terminology, I also want to take a quick look at the types of lights that we're
going to be seeing inside of the engine.
So the types of lights that we have available to us are directional lights, point lights,
spot lights, rectangular lights.
And now we start to get into the more interesting ones, which are the skylight, which will be
able to capture the scene as a whole and provide indirect lighting for the entire scene.
And then these last two, HDRI backdrops in sun and sky, they actually are plugins that
you have to enable, but they give you essentially a set of blueprints that combine a few lighting
concepts that we see here to give you a particular setup that might be useful for you.
So we will take a look at how to enable these and load them, but we'll be doing that inside
of the engine.